Welcome. Thank you for being here for
happiness. So let's start, um, what,
start with your sports.
You both are in fairly uncommon sports.
How did you initially get involved in
losing and flipping multiple times a year
on skis? Uh, at an early
age to become an Olympian?
Okay.
Uh,
so I grew up close to lake
placid in upstate New York
and my parents volunteered
at the Olympics in 1980 at the lose track.
So I had been skiing already and
I went with my parents to, uh,
to see lose every day.
Uh,
so I saw the best athletes in the
world competing and lake placid is,
it's a really small town, so I kind
of got the Olympic bug and saw other,
I saw a figure skating and hockey
and I saw Eric Heiden when is metals?
So I was like all excited
about the Olympics and after
the games there was a two
week, a luge camp. So my parents let me
skip school and go to luge camp. Uh, God,
honest led,
loved it from the very first time.
And at the end of the two weeks I won.
I won the junior Olympics race in
my age group. And that was kind of,
that was the beginning of
the next 18 years on a sled.
And how old were you when you first
went to lose you? Really? You're gonna
lose camp.
Yeah.
11, 11, 11 which is pretty
typical. So in a, in Luge,
there are tracks like a dozen or so
tracks around the world and you, you know,
you don't get very many runs
on each track every year.
So it really takes years to a, to be good
and to be successful internationally.
So 10 or 11 is pretty typical
for a jumping on a sled. Yeah.
And what about you?
Yeah,
well I,
it's kind of a family affair in our house.
So my brother was actually an aerialist
on the US ski team for many years,
way before I got into it. I was 21
when I actually got into the sport,
so a little bit later.
But um, yeah, so he,
my brother was in it and I was
actually at school going, uh,
going to school down at Florida
State University. And Yeah,
a lot of good skin down that
way. Um, but uh, you know,
there wasn't a lot athletically for
me to get involved in down there.
I was actually riding horses and doing
gymnastics growing up a time and both my
brother and I skied since we could walk,
come from a very,
very avid skiing family. But, um, anyway,
so I decided I was either going to take
a semester off and go to winter park,
Colorado and ski.
Um,
w where my brother was skiing with a
freestyle club there or I was transferring
to the University of New Hampshire where
there was an equestrian riding team.
So I first went to winter park,
went out there,
always thought I'd be a bump scare,
a mogul skier.
My brother did Ariel's
I thought he was nuts.
There is no way I would've ever done that.
So anyway,
when out and with air,
with freestyle,
you usually do all the
events at a regional level.
So I did and I actually
did the best in. So, um,
obviously it didn't transfer to Unh.
I ended up coming out to Salt Lake City
and training with a coach out there and
basically I was the only woman,
um,
training with five other
men out there. And, um,
it took a little convincing for the coach
Steve and let me come and train. So, um,
yeah, so it's been kind of, you
know, then I, then I was on, um,
basically about 12 years on the US team.
So.
So what was that training like
from when you first started to,
right before your first Olympics?
Was the schedule like and the effort that
goes into two becoming one of the best
in your sports in the world?
Yeah, absolutely. Um, do you want,
sure. I can start. So I, uh,
I was on the national team for 14 years
and I think Tracy will probably agree,
a competing on the level that we did
is basically a full time job. Uh,
so the,
uh,
the off season is when most of the like
really intense physical training takes
place. So, uh, for Luge, it's a, it's,
they're kind of two components
a and it's the start,
which is the only chance that
you have to accelerate the sled.
And then once you pull off from the
handles and you wear spikes on your
fingertips, paddle down the ramp, uh,
and then you lie down and then it's all
about skill and how well you can drive,
uh, drive the lines. So, uh, in the
summertime we would do a lot of sort of,
you know,
basic training at first and then it's
all about sort of power and quickness and
speed, uh, on the start.
So a lot of upper body back core work and
a lot of like Olympic Olympic lifting,
uh, in the, in the
summertime. And then in the,
in the winter we would be,
uh,
on the road from usually at the
beginning of October until December.
So usually 10 weeks in the
fall you'd come home, uh,
for like a week at Christmas and it was
kind of enough time to wash your clothes,
eat a couple of meals that your mom made.
And then I'm back on the road for
another eight weeks for the World Cup and
world championship season. So, uh,
definitely a kind of year round and,
and I, I was able to work actually a
undergrad into that schedule because a,
I went to Dartmouth and it had,
it's on quarters.
So I would go with the luge team in
the fall and winter and then I'd go to
school in the spring and summer. I was
there for a little longer than four years.
Yeah. So for Ariel's, um,
basically it starts on a trampoline
and there are hours and hours of,
you know,
refining your skills for doing back
flips and twists and multiple twists and
multiple flips and all of that.
And you're in a big a harness as well,
which has a spinning belt,
so that's attached to a rope.
So there's a lot of trampoline
training is a really, really big,
big facet of it.
Then you actually transfer it to water
ramping where you coming down. Um,
there's a lake placid and park city have
to water ramp facilities and you come
down the ramps.
I'm on plastic surface,
go off and land into a big swimming pool
with all your, your skis, your boots.
Um, you know, you have a life jacket on,
usually have a dry suit or a wetsuit
and I'm helmet of course. And uh,
I've always had the question, do your
ski boots get wet? And I'm like, Oh yeah,
they get wet and we break skis
and all sorts of things, but,
and water does hurt. Um, it's a great way
to train. That's where you, like I said,
you, there's a very long
process in taking what, um,
what you see on snow.
Um,
there's a qualification process
for every single jump that you,
that you do on snow. So you'd have
to do it a certain number of times.
You have to qualify it in front of a u
s team coach safely five times in a row,
um,
and then then you're able to transfer
it onto snow once the season starts.
And then, you know, I think
like what Cameron said,
I think one of the misconceptions
about, um, you know,
Olympic athletes is that the only thing
they train for and compete and are the
Olympics and we have a World Cup circuit
that we are on every single year.
And so it goes to our
sports, uh, the Olympics.
But right now we have world
championships every other year.
So we were on tour from December
all the way to April every year.
And then our summer training also, we
would do trampoline starting in May, um,
you know, through October. So we had
a little bit of time off in April,
a little bit of time off in October.
But other than that it was,
it was year round training for sure.
Yeah.
And so you've obviously did a lot of the
trampoline training, all these things.
How have you seen the training evolve
from when you started doing it your first
couple of years to where we are today
with the technology and the advancements
that have happened? Yeah. Well, I I
know for Ariel's, you know, it, I think,
um, the water ramp facility
itself has become better.
The jumps are the jumps that we
used to use for water ramping.
We're not as similar as the jumps that we
now, you know, create on snow. But now,
now they are very,
very similar.
So that transition from water to
snow is not nearly as different.
And really the only thing that you have
to modify for on snow is the Landing
Hill.
Cause we obviously land on a very,
very steep landing hill and water
your landing pretty much. Um,
you really don't try to
land straight up and down.
But we tried to land with our tips
going into the water. But um, you know,
aside from that there's still tons
of trampoline training and um,
I don't think that there's,
I think where at least for Ariel's
it's changed as more time on snow.
The more time that we can
actually train on snow.
So more training camps have come
about where we've been able to,
where the team's been able
to be on snow more often. So,
so with the, with Luge, the a,
it's hard to see when you watch it on
TV or even when you're standing at the
track. A sled goes why it, you know,
90 miles an hour. But they, uh,
the sled is, there's a lot of
technology that goes into the sled.
So a single sled and women,
a women just do singles.
Men can do singles or doubles,
but the single sled weighs 50 pounds.
So it is a,
there's a part that you lie in your
body is sort of in a fiberglass shell,
a their handles that you hold onto.
And then runners that go the whole length
of the sled attached to that on the
bottom are steals. And, uh, they are, um,
there's sort of a lot of technological
espionage and the in the sport.
So people are always trying to see what
other countries are doing. Uh, and, uh,
when I was on the team, and it's,
it's definitely still true today. Uh,
our coach would make the sleds, so
everything, uh, so it's, uh, you know,
from the fiberglass to the runners,
the steels are a,
that's probably the most technologically
a complicated part of the sled and the
most important. And it's really, um,
it's like very nuanced sort of what a
metals comprise the runners and what goes
fast. And it's, and sometimes
it's just really hard to know.
You might have a steels that are made
like two made exactly the same material at
the same time, and one will be faster
than the other. So a, so it's like, yes,
there's a lot of technology, but there's
also some art to it, uh, as well.
Um, so I, I had a,
one of our assistant coaches from
Italy one summer, he said, okay,
so, uh, you know, we think
these steels are really fast,
but what I want you to do this summer
is to, and I'm not joking here, um,
bury them in your backyard so the,
the sun and the moon can get on the
steels. And I think we'll go even faster.
I was like, okay, I'll do that. I'll
try and eat. And they were fast.
I have no idea if it was
like burying in the backyard,
I it required a lot of
sanding to get the rust off.
But um, so yeah, so there is a,
there's definitely a lot
of technology in the, uh,
in the sleds I didn't mention before.
A one part of the training in the
summertime is practicing the start, uh,
on ice. So in lake placid there's
an indoor start ramp facility,
so you can, um, you can
practice the, the start on ice,
you go down the ramp and then up
up the other side because it's a,
it makes a really big difference sort of
being on ice versus being on, you know,
wheels, which is possible, but
you don't really get the same, uh,
the same sort of feel when one of the
star ramps in. Um, it's actually the one,
uh, at the track and laplant in France
where the Olympics were in 92. Uh,
so the ramp is so steep that when
you're so it would lose, you know,
you're sitting on the sled at the start,
hands around the handles.
Normally you can see the, you know, you
can see the ramp, see the first curve,
this ramp, it's so steep you can't see
it. So you're sitting at the start,
you can't see the ramp and you
just see the first curve. Okay.
I hope I'm going to go straight down.
There was a Dupre a little,
so that leads into my question,
which is most of the audience,
I don't want to assume anyone,
maybe some people have,
but most of the Saudis has probably
never gone down a loser ramp,
80 plus miles an hour or
flipped multiple times on sees
what's,
can you describe that experience of being
in the air or what'd you get down that
ramp and the first curve? Go
ahead. Um, oh goodness. You know,
um,
cash.
It is so difficult to describe what
it's like to be 60 feet in the air.
I was actually the first woman in the
world to do a triple twisting double
backflip and a double twisting, triple
back flip. Can you demonstrate? Yeah.
But, um, so, you know, um, oh my goodness.
It is, I think, uh, you know,
I'm scared of heights. So if
you put me on top of real,
I know everyone says, oh my gosh, you're
an aerialist, how can you be afraid of,
but just looking out, you know, in down
is just a the nerve wracking to me.
It makes my legs all week.
But, um, going, you know,
you're doing something in the air,
you're coming down,
you're not focused on
really how high you are,
cause that's what you need to get your
feet under you. But, um, you know,
it's just an amazing,
amazing feeling of, um, you know,
like I said,
it's hard to put in words.
You're at the top of the Enron and you
definitely have to figure out how to
channel the fear in a really
positive, productive way. Otherwise,
you'll never be an aerialist.
But you know,
the adrenaline rush that
you get, um, you know,
coming down and doing a triple flip and
landing and skiing away when you're down
at the bottom,
it is such a intense amount of
emotion in all of six seconds.
Um, and it is, it's just amazing. I always
say this and I love my husband to death.
I really haven't found quite something
that's given me quite the adrenaline rush,
the areas that might be too much
information, but nonetheless,
um,
that's the way it goes
onto you.
Okay.
Uh, so, uh, so, uh, Lucia solutions, the,
it's the fastest of all of the sliding
sports. So it's faster than bobsled.
It's faster than skeleton,
and it's actually the only
Olympic sport time to that.
That was in the of a of a second. So
I'm the fastest track in the world is a,
is Vancouver,
uh,
from the men start is
about 97 miles an hour. Um,
so I've not gone that fast.
I've been from the, uh,
the men start in park city and
go on about 87 miles an hour.
So fast enough. Uh, so if you've
driven that fast in your car,
uh,
imagine sort of that speed lying on your
back on a fairly small sled going down
in an ice track. Um,
some of the tracks are a,
and every track is different, so some
tracks are sort of wide open curves.
Um, of course like you have to steer on
all of them, but some, some requires less,
some required less steering.
So the one in park city is a little
more like an autobahn. It's very fast,
not a ton of steering of really
fun kind of smooth ride down.
There are other tracks, however, that
are really technically difficult.
And if you don't steer in exactly the
right place at exactly the right time,
you'll crash. So, uh, I'd like those
tracks and I was, I was good at those.
Great. So let's go to the first
Olympics. As you both are multiply, uh,
time Olympians at first Olympics.
What was the emotion when
you first qualified and then
what was the emotional at
the opening ceremonies when you're there?
Were you really excited to
be there and ready to go?
Or were you really nervous about the
competition and kind of what was going
through your head?
So my first Games wiz and 88,
and Calgary and a and that
year to qualify for the team,
there were a series of races, uh,
in lake placid. So I qualified,
uh, and, and I, it's like, you know,
when you qualify, it's like, okay,
I've made the Olympic team
super excited about that.
But it wasn't really until I walked into
the opening ceremonies that I thought,
oh my gosh,
like I've made the Olympic team,
I'm here representing the United
States and, you know, all of that.
I was 19 at my first game,
so I had spent sort of eight
years preparing for that, uh,
that moment. And, uh, with that games,
I didn't really have any particular
expectation about my finish and like,
I didn't really expect that I
had a chance to win a medal.
So I was really just going to, you know,
to do my best and, uh, and hopefully have,
you know, as good at race as I possibly,
uh, as a possibly good. Uh, so I,
that games, I was, uh, I
was ninth, I had great runs.
I was like the happy with the
happy with the results and, uh,
had a few more games after
that. But, um, yeah, so it's a,
it's at that moment I think when you
walk into the opening ceremonies is a,
is a pretty special one.
Yeah. Yeah. So Mine, mine
was 1994 and I was 26.
Um, but, and actually Cameron was the
flag bearer at the 1994 Olympic Games.
So that's, that's a huge
honor. And that they're voted,
the flag bearers voted by
there are our teammates.
So she was voted by all of us to be
the flag bearer, which was amazing. Um,
for me also,
my brother was actually after he retired,
went on to coach the Australian freestyle
ski team and Ariel's, so 1994 is a,
again, a family affair. We, um,
he was coaching aerials while
I was competing, so it was,
and my parents were over
there. So that was, um,
something that was just obviously amazing.
And like Cameron said,
the process of, of at least
for freestyle, um, you know,
of qualifying for the Games is a
pretty long one. And so we know, one,
we didn't find out our team until like
two weeks before the game. So yes, that's,
that's a step.
Um,
but my mentality going into
all the Olympics as well
was to make sure that I had
a degree of difficulty that if I,
if I want or could win,
I just put myself in a place to win.
And that was just always like the
Olympics is not a place to hold back. So,
um, that was, yeah, that was just, I mean,
Lillehammer just for sure was just
an amazing, amazing first games.
Um,
but I will say my last
games real quick is that it's rare that
an Olympian gets to compete in their own
home country when, um, during your career,
let alone your own backyard. So
I, I live in Park City, Utah.
So the fact that Salt Lake City held
the 2002 Olympic Games was amazing.
And that was how I got to end
my career. So it's been, it was,
it was pretty cool.
So that's thought about going
for a fifth of 1998 was my,
a was my last Olympics in Nagano,
Japan. And for that reason,
because 2002 wasn't in the United
States, I thought, oh, maybe one more,
but, uh, uh,
decided to go to law school
instead of nearly as much fun as,
although I was a, I was in park city
because, um, uh, as Tracy mentioned,
I, uh, I carried the flag at
the opening ceremonies in 94,
which was a huge honor and really
humbling and to be there, you know,
sort of for the u s team and really
for everybody back, uh, back home, uh,
as well. So, uh, although
when I was at each,
each sport nominates someone to carry the
flag and then the team captains of all
of the sports vote on who
will be elected and, uh,
Dan Jansen and Bonnie Blair were
nominated and I was like, okay,
so this is kind of going
to be like the Oscars.
I'm really honored to have been
nominated and this great pool of people.
And then, uh, and then I got
picked. Yeah, it's a, so I was,
I was super surprised and really,
really honored. But in a, in part,
in a Salt Lake City,
the organizing committee invited all of
the flag bearers to come and run with
the torch from the opening ceremony
stadium to the first metal ceremony.
So a, and everyone who had carried the
flag from basically who was living and who
could come and manage to, uh, carry the
torch and they said that they're like,
well, you're young and in
pretty good shape and all of
that. And I was like, okay,
I'm working in a law firm on Wall Street,
like 20 hours a day. And I can't remember
the last time I worked out. So, um,
so when we were running,
you had to run behind like the van
with the camera on you the entire time.
So I thought, and I was like, oh my gosh,
my arm's really tired. If I drop it, like,
should I switch hands?
Like that's not really going to look good,
but if I drop it, that's even worse.
But it was all, it was a huff and puff.
I know. It's like, oh my gosh. Yeah.
So is that more nerve wracking or carrying
the flag and the opening ceremony?
Well, before I walked into the, uh,
to the stadium at the opening
ceremonies in Lovell Hommer,
the director of marketing
for USA Luge said, Oh, uh,
so you know, like 2 billion
people are watching the Olympics,
so don't trip and fall with
the flag. I was like, really?
Like you had to say that,
tell me that right now. I did it.
It was a, it was all good. But,
so Tracy brought up good point that you
got to compete in your home country and
really hometown.
Yeah.
Did you ever feel when you went on the
road that you didn't get enough practice
time or the courses were different or
I guess what was the experience being
at a road course or was it common
practice since you traveled?
Yeah. Yeah. No, you know, I think
one of the things that I, you know,
even in, in Cameron Sport, it's, you have,
that's one of the things as an athlete
you have to be able to do is be able to
change from site to site from week
to week and you have to be flexible.
You have to know how to adjust
and deal with obstacles and,
and all that kind of thing. So,
um, and you know, not really,
I mean that was something throughout all,
all our years of training that we were
used to on a weekly basis. Like I said,
World Cup was a different
site every single week.
So every Sunday we would travel somewhere
else and then train a couple of days
and compete and do it again somewhere
else. So you just learn to adapt.
What about the tracks lose track?
Well yet,
so lose tracks are very different.
But I'll just mention that when I made
the national team when I was 15 and my
first couple of years on the team,
there was still east Germany and Soviet
Union and Yugoslavia and like we went to
all of those places. So it was, I mean,
it was a really great adventure
among other things being on the,
being on the team at that time. Food
was always a challenge. I'm like,
I cannot identify that thing,
whatever is on my plate right now.
So you'd always bring like peanut butter
and jelly with you just like just in
place. Um, so yeah, lose tracks
are uh, definitely like very,
very different from track to track.
And a,
the u s we were at a little bit of a
disadvantage because Germany has four
tracks,
a German sort of run the international
federation and there tend to be a three
or four World Cup's on
German tracks every year. Uh,
so usually the way it works with
countries is that if you have a track,
uh, us has a track a that everyone
else wants to train on your Germany,
they have attract, people want to train
on, you might swap a training times.
No one wanted to train on
the track and lake placid.
So it was kind of worth nothing, uh,
in, uh, in sort of track time leverage.
So, so we ended up getting, you
know, like not great training times.
And uh, with the, with the
lose track, it's about, uh,
so loose bobsled and skeleton all go
on the same track from the top of the
course. The, some tracks are
nearly a mile long, so they're,
most of them are concrete, their pipes
running throughout the entire track.
And there's a big,
um,
refrigeration plant that pumps some
ammonia compound throughout the pipes and
you spray water on the track and it
makes it makes ice. Um, so, uh, however,
uh,
one thing that the Germans like to do
when we were training on their tracks was
like, give us track time at like nine
o'clock at night. Uh, and yeah, great.
And then six o'clock the next
morning, uh, and then, uh,
they would crank up the
refrigeration. So, uh,
it grows like frost on the ice.
So it would,
the track would be really slow when
we were training and in, in Luge, the,
you know, it's, it's so fast and it's
time to the thousandth of a second.
So if the track is even
like half a second slow,
it makes a really big difference in
your timing and in how you steer.
So training there would be like all sorts
of frost on the ice and then race day,
I mean literally you would sit on your
sled and like look at the ice at the
start and think like, oh, like I can see
my reflection in the ice. And it's like,
so I used to be like really hard
and really smooth and very fast.
So that was always a little bit of
a challenge. But like Tracy said,
you adapt it something that you know,
you learn how to do as an athlete.
Yeah, yeah. I, you know, I, that's, it's
so different for Ariel's. It's like, so,
you know,
we have,
we have four jumped and there's usually
two double kickers into triple kickers
and we arrived there and they're just big,
you know,
piles of snow that are, you know,
that we have to basically go shape.
So there's certain shapers on our, um,
you know, from different countries.
And so each jump likes to be his shape,
just a little bit different.
Sometimes people like Steve Jumps,
some people like a little bit less, um,
at the top, so it doesn't throw you
up quite so much if those you out.
But everybody, I don't
know, you know, that, that,
that definitely we all
trained at the same time.
Everybody was very supportive and,
and not that that's not an extreme sport,
but, um, we, I don't know, there was
definitely a camaraderie between,
um,
between our countries and between everyone
to make sure that the jumps were just
right for everybody. Um, so yeah,
we have family that's a coach from another
countries will, yeah, exactly that too.
Um, but yeah, um,
it definitely a little different
dynamic I think. And, and I think the,
the Olympics in Vancouver probably
pretty good example of that because a,
so prior to Vancouver, the two other
times Canada hosted the Olympics,
so Montreal in [inaudible] 76
and then 88 and Calgary, uh,
they didn't win any gold medals
zero at home, which is really,
really unusual.
Usually you kind of have the,
like the home field advantage and
you're going to win more gold medals.
A Canada had not done that,
so they were determined,
I think in Vancouver to make sure that
they won gold. So one of the strategies,
they funded, a lot of athletes they
thought had the chance to win medals.
And then the other strategy was to limit
access to Olympic venues for a athletes
from other countries. So if you, I mean,
if you are a figure skater or a
hockey player, maybe, you know,
not such a big deal because a lot of the
rinks are like fairly similar and maybe
a little bit different,
you know,
ice quality or it's slightly
different dimensions, but you know,
fairly much the same,
uh, loose, not so much.
And that was the fastest
track in the world.
So actually the day before the opening
ceremonies and athlete from Georgia, uh,
died, uh, on the track. So he had 25 runs
and I think the average Canadian head,
like 250. Uh, so
yeah. Yeah, it matters. So
let's pivot post Olympics. Um,
so there's a lot of Olympians
in some cases struggle posts,
a professional athletic career
and pivoting to a new career. Um,
Youtube I've done very well.
So can you tell us what you're doing now
and talk about maybe your foundation as
well? Sure. Um, yeah. So Gosh,
I am retired after obviously the 2000
actually I retired after the 98 games,
took two years off and went down to
California and started a division of my
brother's sports marketing company.
Um, it a warm place for two years.
I needed a break anyway. Um, yeah,
and started a casting a sports casting
a company and placing athletes in
different sports production, mainly
commercial and print stuff. Um,
it was a great break and I came back
obviously for the 2002 games and then
afterwards, um, went back
to casting. So, you know, I,
I feel just very fortunate. I mean, I
did, I did finish getting my degree,
took me 10 years, but I had done that
while I was, it took me seven now
I had my 10 year high school reunion
that weekend. I was, uh, walking.
I'm the my college degree.
Yeah. But anyway, um,
yeah. So I, I, you know,
I feel pretty fortunate that I
had a pretty smooth transition.
I also was very much in the eye.
That's just my personality.
Like I knew I had to have
something to move on to. And um,
so having a business that was
already somewhat set up was,
was great. And I did that for a
long time and still doing that.
But also along the way, I, um,
went on a volunteer trip to my mother's
prompting basically. And, uh, um,
ended up starting a foundation
called kids play international.
And this really truly is my,
my absolute passion without a doubt.
And it was really this one little
boy's words, 10 year, 10 year,
10 years olds,
and name's Thomas.
I went out and volunteered trip and
he said to me at the end of the trip,
I can see girls can play.
And the background to that
is that we were there, um,
in Africa and in Malawi,
Africa. Yep. And, um, basically,
of course we are playing soccer.
Um,
but we also introduced a new sports
with the boys and girls over there and
obviously developing countries. Girls
just are not encouraged to play sport.
So when we actually
pulled out, um, you know,
baseball and softball after playing
soccer where the boys were just absolutely
aggressive and the girls stood there
like orange cones and wouldn't interact
very well together. But
we, we pulled out baseball,
softball and it just leveled the playing
field. They had never picked up a bat,
never played, never heard of the
sport and never played the sport.
And it was just for me to watch how
differently boys and girls we're learning
side by side and um,
you know,
just that everything that sport and the
Olympic values have taught me and I,
I'm really came back after that trip and
decided that I wanted to do something
with, um, gender quality and
sports. And so, um, you know,
it's been about 10 years in the making.
We have a year round program in Rwanda,
Africa.
Um,
and it's really all about building better
relationships between boys and girls
from a very young age. And you know,
boys and girls are so segregated, um,
um, in developing countries from an
early age that it's just, you know,
through our program it, it definitely
goes from simple to complex learning. But,
uh,
it's been an amazing,
amazing journey and a such a great way
to be able to take everything that's
sport has given me in debt.
Pay It forward a bit. So cool.
And you're involved too.
I am an athlete ambassador and I've been,
I've been to Rwanda where our program is
a a couple of times and I went first in
2011 and,
uh,
and it was really like one of the best
things I think that I've done sort of at
the, uh, you know, using a sport in a, in
a way that makes it, makes a difference.
So, uh, so I went back this last
summer on a trip that was, uh,
funded by a State
Department grant and it's,
it's amazing to sort of see the difference
that the program has made in the
community. So, not just with the kids,
but the parents and teachers and everyone,
uh, had like really great
stories of how, uh, the,
the let's play fair program
has impacted them personally.
So you went to law school
after I did. So I, uh,
my 98 was my last games and I went to
law school that fall and I decided,
I decided to go to law school because
I had been on the US Olympic Committee
board of directors and on the Athletes
Advisory Council for eight years. And,
uh, there are a lot of lawyers in
sports. I, you know, NBA is, you know,
nothing but attorneys. Uh, so, uh,
it true in Olympic sport as well,
a lot of lawyers practicing or, you
know, working at a sports organization.
And I thought,
oh,
well maybe that's an interesting way to
sort of combine professional career with
my interest in sport. Wasn't quite
sure how that was going to happen,
but it seemed like a, a, a good sort
of general, a direction. Anyway,
so I went to a,
I went to BC for law school and a,
and Yay. Right on. Uh, and, uh, uh,
I spent, uh, I, I've worked, uh, in
new, I've been in New York since, uh,
since I graduated law school. Uh,
so I worked on Wall Street at a big,
big from Milbank tweed, uh, for, for
two years. Kind of went through the, uh,
you know, law firm bootcamp. And, uh,
and then I went to a smaller media and
entertainment. It's a boutique, um,
that had, you know, really
interesting clients. So, uh, we had,
I worked on the last JD Salinger
copyright infringement case.
A Nike was a client.
So I,
I mostly litigated a intellectual
property cases. Um, while I was there,
I also had a,
because I'd been involved with the US
Olympic Committee after I graduated law
school,
I put my name,
there was like a list of lawyers who
were available to athletes who had,
you know,
some kind of issues.
So I put my name on the list and I got
a call from an athlete who had tested
positive for,
uh,
some drug called modafinil
and the rational for like
three or four athletes that
I represented, uh, the
all of them. And, um,
so that I'd settled that case.
And, and when you're a lawyer,
it's like you're learning
something new all the time,
especially when you're litigating.
So I knew, of course, like new,
the whole drug testing routine, but,
uh, it was, it was, you know, from, uh,
from the lawyer's perspective, I kind
of enjoyed the, enjoyed the process.
But at the end of, at the end
of that first case, one of
the, one of my clients, uh,
Christy gains,
so she was a two time gold medalist and
ran on the four by 100 meter relay team
with Marion Jones and probably
see where this is going. They, uh,
she was one of the athletes who were
sort of caught up in the Belko a
investigation in California.
Uh,
and that ended up being like a
16 month long, uh, sort of, uh,
made new law in a, in doe, in the
doping world, a kind of case. But, um,
so I practiced law for
10 years and, uh, the,
the spring of my last year,
um,
I got a call from Nyu and they asked me
to come speak on a panel about women in
sports. So I did that. I
went out to dinner with the
faculty a afterward and, uh,
and want the academic director
at the time. I said, Oh,
we'd love you to come teach a class. I'm
like, right in my free time. Oh, New York.
Okay. Uh, so actually I left my
firm, I went to Rwanda with Tracy,
and then that summer, uh, Nyu,
uh, they sent an email, uh,
was a Monday and they said,
uh,
would you be interested in teaching
international sports governance?
And I thought, well, I know that world.
It's like the IOC and national
Olympic Committees. And I
said, great. I, you know,
I'd love to. Uh, so I
said yes to that. And uh,
and then on Friday they called and
they said, how about sports law?
Can you teach that? I'm like,
well, I don't know what's,
uh, what are the topics? So,
um,
so I looked at this,
it's a pretty broad survey course and a
lot of the things like Ip, I'm like, fine.
Like I, you know, did that for 10
years. It can certainly teach that.
But antitrust and labor law were on the,
on the syllabus. And I said, okay, just,
you know, full disclaimer here, I don't
know anything about these areas of law,
like at all. And they said, oh, that's no
problem. You can learn it. And I'm like,
like, okay. So, uh, and I,
I think that's, you know,
something like that's in my nature anyway,
being a luge athlete.
Like I'm really not afraid of anything.
So I'm like, yeah, sure, why not?
I can do that. So, uh, so I did,
the first semester was a little
bit of a learning curve. Um,
international sports governance was great.
I had terrible reviews and my sports
law class, like I cried. I'm like,
Oh God, it's awful. And I
said, listen, like I, um,
I said to the director said,
I,
if you want to get someone else to teach
the class, totally fine with me. Like,
I don't need this kind of thing.
And, and he said, go, like,
go, you know, take the Christmas
break and come back. But like,
I think you should teach it one more
time. I said, Oh God, all right. Uh,
so I came back and I thought, okay, and,
and again, I think both of us as athletes,
like you were very determined and you
don't get to three or four Olympic Games
without having,
um,
some sense of feeling like you can
accomplish what you set out to do. So.
So I said, okay, like I'll give it
another try. And it was then it was great.
And so at, that was seven years ago.
I'm on the full time faculty in the,
in the sports business program
and uh, I love it. Awesome.
So let's briefly talk with the
Olympics are coming up. Yes. Um,
what advice would you give to a first
time athlete going to the First Olympics?
Oh, okay. I'll go ahead. Um,
Gosh, um, I think I, you know,
you're so obviously focused on just your,
your sport and obviously that's
what you should be focused on and,
and competing.
And all of that.
But I think for me it was always
about also a balance. I could not,
um, at least as for the
way I worked as an athlete,
I could not 24 hours a
day think about my sport.
I really did me a disservice.
And so I always like to try to remind
people to take a little bit of, you know,
do something else that will take your mind
off of it. And, and you know, and that,
that doesn't mean go go party and
the, you know, outside, you know,
before your event or anything like that.
No, no, no, nobody did that. But um,
anyway, um, but or spend too
much time in the cafeteria,
that was the big thing.
Everyone to do not spend so much time the
cafeteria at the inside of the Olympic
Village because that was just the
biggest social social place ever. But um,
anyway, but it, but it
is there. They're really,
you really should just be able to take a
little bit of time away from your sport
and so balance your Olympic experience
and it's okay to, like I said, you know,
you go out and enjoy yourself
mostly after your event,
but even leading up to it,
um, to have a good balance of,
I think just mental it, you
know, the physical side of
it at that point, you know,
you're not rushing. I mean, yes, you're
maintaining whatever you need to do,
but you're not looking to
like get a major workout into,
to hope that your quads are
stronger for landing at that point.
But it's really a mental, it's
such a mental, um, I, you know,
pointed that I always say after the
Olympics, people say like, Gosh, you know,
you know,
how do you,
how do you feel after your events
over after the Olympics are over?
And I literally felt like I had
held my breath for about four years.
And then so when you finally were done,
the exhaustion,
you know, is, it's
really hard to describe,
but it's like you finally get to breathe
again before you start ramping it up
again. But still you, you
do. It's exhausting. So, um,
my advice I'll, you know, it
was just to make sure that you
give yourself a little bit of a break.
So I would say,
um,
to try not to be distracted by everything
that's going on at the Games because,
uh,
Tracy,
I'm sure would agree it is
such a different experience
than any other race that
you, that you go to. So if you're on
the, if you're on the World Cup tour,
you're there with only lose athletes and
everybody goes from track to track and
you see the same people, you know,
a training and a, and in the race.
And in that context with the team,
you stay in a hotel,
you eat all of your meals together.
Like at the same time,
there's a room where you keep,
uh, your sleds, you know,
where you can work on your sleds, you get
your sled. Do you go put it in the van?
You drive to the track. It's pretty,
you know, it's, it's pretty simple. Uh,
at the Olympics it's an entirely
different things. So at, uh, you know,
you're staying at the
village with people from,
I think what I last read for Pyong Chang,
uh,
there are 93 countries right now
sending athletes to the games.
So you're in a village with, you know,
athletes from dozens and dozens of a,
of countries. Uh, you are, you're
not eating necessarily, you know,
where the dining hall is,
is maybe not great where you stay
and where your equipment is stored is
someplace else.
So like,
logistically it's much more complicated
and I mean there's a, there's a lot,
there's so much going on.
Um, you know, being mobile,
definitely media requests, um, you know,
press conferences and so there's
a lot that can sort of draw you,
I think outside of your,
sort of your zone of a,
of focus during the games lose.
I felt like we were always
really lucky because, uh,
the races at the beginning
of the Olympics every time.
So it's the opening
ceremonies are on Friday,
men's singles race on Saturday and Sunday
the women are on Monday and Tuesday
doubles on Wednesday and then you're done.
So it's like six days into the games.
There are 11 more days to go
and you can go and you can go,
you go see your teammates compete and
then you figure out which a sponsors are
having the best parties.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
See for areas as their competent moguls
was always first and Ariel's was always
second week.
So we actually,
for Nagano did not even show
up for opening ceremonies.
We were at a training camp before we,
even before we came.
So we came well into the first
week of the Games. Um, so,
uh, yeah. Yeah. And there are, there's
definitely a lot of distractions for sure.
I always found it so nice.
Like you said, you know, when,
when we actually got to our site, it
felt like home. Um, because you know,
you're obviously that's,
that's the familiar I already have of,
of your sport being there and you're
right. Nothing can prepare you for the,
when you look down and,
well it's different probably
at the top of the track,
but for us at the top of a of a hill,
you look out and see the
entire, you know, spect,
all the spectators and it's massive. Can
there is like, we obviously have had,
yeah, the spectators at World
Cups and world championships.
Nothing was like the first time I was
like, I was like, oh, oh wow this, okay,
let's not, let's not
focus on that, you know,
let's just turn around and just
think about what we're doing.
Not everyone down there.
In fact,
this is very funny story and I'm in a
2002 as in deer valley where our site was.
I was at the top of the hill just training
and can I just healing somebody down
at the bottom really like just
annoying yelling something.
I was that, yeah, Lansky do it, practice
jump, come down, back up. Same thing.
Come down again and I'm really like,
wow,
I don't know why this is really
irritated me. It was my family.
That's why it was my family. And I
was like, oh my gosh, I went over,
found my phone,
called my brothers,
and you need to go over there and tell
them to be quiet. I was like, oh my gosh,
that is really annoying. So it's
amazing that that, you know, kind of,
uh, you heard that, but yes.
Yes, exactly. So anyway,
so I do want to open up
to audience questions.
There's microphones on
both sides and maybe
just mentioned that we're both going
to the Olympics and pf Chang's. So, uh,
I am a, I'm an arbitrator on the
Court of Arbitration for Sport and uh,
I'm one of six arbitrators who will decide
any doping case that comes up at the
Olympics. So I'll be over there for
the whole time doing that. Yeah. Yeah.
I think all of the Russian
cases will be taken care of
and Tracy is going to be there as well.
Yeah. Getting an award. Well, yeah.
So I have a fun question when all people,
if people want to start lining up my
phone question is, what is the craziest,
wildest family friendly Corey of things
you saw during the Olympic Village in
the Olympic Village? Goodness.
Family friendly. Hmm. Wow.
Goodness. Uh hmm. Well,
I don't know that I have
any. Yeah, yeah. Ah,
I'm a lawyer. I have no stories
and you have no stories.
Yeah, exactly. No, you know,
I think just with the, the Olympic Village
really it has everything in anything.
If you wanted to go get your hair done,
go get your nails done. Um, you know,
they had, uh, they had, uh, um,
you know, disco, Yellow Bar.
No, no, there was no alcohol
inside. I do have a story. Okay.
Speaking of bars. Yeah. There's no,
there was no alcohol on. Oh, well,
campus wasn't finish your
story. Yeah. Anyway. Um,
and yeah. You know, and
I dunno, there's, yeah,
it was just very much in all inclusive.
Uh,
but it was just a very unique,
all inclusive.
Yes, yes. Yeah. So, uh, in a, in 1992, a,
the Olympics were in France
in Albertville. And, uh, the,
the main village was in la,
in the city of Albertville at,
but none of the venues
were very close to town.
So you had to drive
basically two hours to,
to any venue and you'd have to drive
down a valley and then up at mountain.
And then to get to any other venue,
you'd have to go back down
the mountain backs, you know,
down the valley to Albertville and
then out in some other directions.
So at that games,
we lose the illusion.
Athletes and bobsled athletes were
together in a sort of separate village.
Uh, and it was a club med,
uh, in La Pylon and there,
and there was beer and wine on tap.
Well, it was that they were treated,
it was like the sort of club med practices
were still going on, like, you know,
drive around with a cheese called and,
and I think after,
maybe like the first five
days of the Games, I,
maybe we drank like all of the wine
and beer and ate all of the cheese or
something. But they're like, okay, maybe
we need to cut a cuddle a little bit off.
Yeah. Yep. Exactly.
Like audience question.
Thanks so much for coming. I'm curious
just given how intense the training is,
uh,
between games,
how athletes support themselves
sort of year to year to year as,
as their careers sort of stretch?
Yeah, great question.
Uh, so, uh, so I was a,
I was on the national team for
14 years and uh, and lose, uh,
had and still has some, uh, there's like
a race incentive programs so you can,
depending on where you finish in World
Cup races, uh, win money, that's a,
that comes from the u s Luge Association.
So I did well enough that I, uh,
I got enough money that, uh, that
I supported myself through that.
And there were also grants
available like through the, uh,
through the US Olympic
committees. So, so I,
I feel like I was fairly fortunate in
that respect that I didn't have to,
you know, work like that much. I did,
you know, some at school, but, uh,
but otherwise I didn't really
have that really big challenge,
I think of sort of balancing work and, uh,
and training at the same time. But, uh,
so, so I think some athletes sort of
survive that way. Some have, you know,
sponsorships that help support
them and then others I think,
I think I can can be a
really big challenge.
Yeah, absolutely. You know, support
yourself. Yeah. Yeah. Same here.
I mean we would have ski sponsors,
boots, sponsors. I had gear sponsors,
so you would set up a retainer with
your sponsor and then a victory schedule
depending on how well you did throughout
the year or if you made the world
championship team.
He um,
you get a bonus for that are obviously
Olympic team and all of that.
And also for us the way you
were on a team B team c team,
so you would get some funding from your
federation as well cover, you know, uh,
you know, flight and travel and
training expenses basically. But,
um, you know, having said that,
exactly, what's really difficult,
I think in general with is when you're
trying to come up through the ranks,
it's such a double edged sword because
you can't get sponsors without results.
Well, you can't get results until
you actually start competing.
And so it is so difficult I think for,
for upcoming upcoming athletes too,
to be able to,
unless you have parents that can finance
it, you do, you have to get a second job.
Eric Burgiss gold medalist
in 1998 lived out of his car,
ate peanut butter and
jelly sandwiches for,
I don't know how many summers in years.
I mean that you just wanted to do it.
One good thing is the Olympic training
centers now lake placid and Colorado
Springs, depending on your sport, you can
go there and live, live and have that.
But again, you have to also have
worked your way up to a certain point.
So it's difficult. Yeah, it's not a, it's
not always an easy, unfortunately you,
you probably lose some really incredible
talent just due to lack of support.
And I, and I think in Olympic sport,
most athletes don't have, you know,
really big sponsors or a
ton of financial support.
So like the Michael Phelps
of the world are, you know,
very few and far between
in Olympic sports.
So most of us do it because you love it.
11 yeah. The shelf life of even a
gold medalist these days is so short,
especially now with the
Olympics being every two years.
So as soon as you know the winter
games are over, boom, you're,
you've got maybe a month to
kind of really, um, you know,
if you want to meddle in and do
everything with media that you can try to,
you know,
reap those benefits.
But then sponsors are looking at the
next Olympics already right after that.
So again, there's, there's
clearly exceptions to that,
the to those rules for sure.
But majority of Olympians, you gotta love
what you do. You got to love the sport,
you got to love it. Um,
you're not going to,
even if you are a gold metal does
not mean you are set for life. So
audience question. Hi.
I have two questions.
The first is actually related to what
you're just talking about with this shift
from being every two years this winter
and summer versus when they were
concurrent, like how you saw things
change. And the other is, uh,
can you talk about your
day to day or like a week,
what would a week look like with
training and how did your training groups
changed as he went from one
Olympics to the next? So, uh, the,
I, I kind of went through that
a, the transition from when, uh,
the summer and winter games were
in the same year or two, you know,
being staggered every,
every two. Uh, so, uh,
1992 was the last year that summer in
winter we're in the same year and then
winter was again in [inaudible] 94.
So normally, which, Eh, you know,
it sounds great, like I had four Olympics
in 10 years, but actually that was a,
it was a really quick turnaround because
normally like after our games you,
you've kind of got a like a year where
you might experiment with your equipment
and try a new sled or some
different things that,
because you've got cover in time leading
up to the next games. But after 92,
it was like,
okay,
we're actually that next season you
were qualifying for the Olympics again,
a already. So I think though that
it's for winter sports particularly,
I think it's,
it's good that it's a,
that the games are every two years
because the media can, uh, can focus on,
um, you know, give as much attention
almost. Uh, it's a winter as a, as,
as the summer. So I think that, I know
for and in general it's a, it's positive.
Um, and uh, on the, on
the training, uh, um,
front in the,
it's so it's different sort of in the
winter and the summer sort of in season
and out of season. But uh, in
season usually a, if you're,
we would be at like a track for no
longer than a week. So if you're in the,
if you're in the World Cup season,
the race ends on Sunday,
you pack up all of your stuff and
we lose like the equipment is heavy.
And uh, one time we were in the, we
were in the airport and there was a,
a scale in the floor and we actually
put all of the stuff on to it.
You had to weigh it. And we're always,
we're paying like extra baggage fees.
But when we literally
had a ton of equipment,
so you had to pack that up every Sunday
into the cargo van and then you drive to
the next place. So usually then Monday,
like afternoon, you'd be on the track,
you train twice a day on the track, get
a physical workout in, work on your sled,
take a nap, eat. So it's a,
you're, you're pretty much in a,
in a routine that summertime
it's, you know, you might be,
I was at Dartmouth a lot of,
a lot of the time or in lake placid and
that's more like in the gym I'm doing
start practice and more,
more physical training.
Yeah. Yeah. Um, yeah, so I,
my first Olympics was 94 and I, I, my
first year on the team was 91. So, um,
you know that your,
your having been in the Olympics
and then have to turn around.
I did not experience that,
but um,
but I was actually very happy when it
got on the team that the Olympics were
coming again in two years. So for
me, um, yeah, uh, you know, that's,
I agree. I think it's good
for Winter Olympic, uh,
Olympics to be its own,
um, you know, its own year,
so to speak, because I do think that when
they were concurrent that Eh, you know,
summer always kind of overshadow
winter. So, um, anyway,
I think that that's, I think it's a
good thing. Um, so training, yes. Gosh,
for training, for Ariel's. Um,
our summer time training is
definitely far more intense than, um,
than it is when we're on the road.
Once you're on the road and competing
week to week, it's more of a maintenance,
um, type of, um, you know,
uh, mentality so to speak.
But our summer training
definitely was pretty intense.
We would get up and have a
couple hours on the trampoline.
We do a couple of hours, uh, water
ramping. Um, we'd have lunch,
we'd go to the gym for another couple
hours and sometimes even a trampoline
session at nighttime. So it just,
it kind of, uh, we inside the gym,
so to speak. But, um, so yeah.
And you were just really
trying to, you know, you would
definitely, I think it, it,
you know, it depends on where you are
in your career. Obviously if you're,
you're just starting
off and you're a rookie,
you're really trying to do a
lot more jumps in qualifying,
a lot of jumps as your, you know,
becoming more of a veteran on the team.
You're trying to have a
different type of training.
It's quality over quantity basically.
Um, so that's, that's kind of how,
how it worked. Um, you know,
in the summertime everyone kind of had
more of an individualized plan depending
on what you were, what you were doing,
uh, with your, with your jumps. But,
and then, yeah, the winner pretty
much with Cameron said, I mean,
it's week to week train traveling.
Um, you'd get into a site on Monday,
you would work on the jumps.
You would hopefully at least have one
day of training on the jumps sometimes
with whether you didn't even get to train
on the jump till the day you competed,
which was never fun. But usually you have
at least one or two days of training.
You'd compete back up, move
on to the next, next place.
So it'd probably one thing I would add
to this for both of us would be, um,
maybe later in your career you might
spend some time in sports medicine and
doing some rehab on your various joints.
A,
I've had four knee surgeries and
one on each shoulders. So, uh, it's,
it takes a tick, definitely takes
a toll on the body for a skier.
I actually have both my acs,
which is very rare. So I've been,
I feel like I got out of the
sport pretty unscathed. I, yeah,
I definitely have some things, but
Tracy, Cameron, thank you for being here.
Thank you so much for coming
and, uh, that's it. Awesome.
Thanks everybody. Thanks.